they haven't been that aggro the
seagulls have
that's actually blackheaded gull i think
is it we did come up to the north a lot
when i was a kid
and we ate a lot of fish and chips
blythe beach on the north
east coast this a part of england
determined to reverse economic decline
and build a better future
we came to blythe six months ago after
the general election when political
identities had been scrambled
and dozens of seats like this one had
turned
from red to blue on the back of boris
johnson's promises
over brexit and we were always going to
come back here
to see how he was doing but we didn't
know that we've been coming back
after a global pandemic that has turned
our world upside down and it's places
like this in the northeast places like
blithe
that could be worst affected by the
fallout of covid19
lockdown emptied the shops and cafes
here
but blyth cautiously reopening this is
dot's first day out since february
so you haven't been out for five months
you look good though the hair looks good
the tan looks good
[Laughter]
there's three things that i like
[Music]
do you think do you think we could be
living with this for a long time this
coronavirus
it's gonna go on a long time
yeah i think it's going to be hard for
blythe it will
i mean the shops that's closing
you know there's a lot of shops closed
blight used to be a heaven place
do you hope that with the conservative
government and it could get better
are you so passionate about it in
you know a lovely place it's it's just
forgotten
forgotten yeah but you think if they do
what they said they do they'll keep
blind they'll keep the seat because
blind was labor for seven decades i mean
now we've got coronavirus and we've got
a change
peter came to england to work the
government saved his business
i think boris johnson's doing a good job
as prime minister or a bad job
i think he do what he can
he does what he can yeah he does what he
can is it enough
sir you know human it's never enough
isn't it
it's everybody's saying but i think he
did a good job so you're
pretty pleased with the government are
you yeah where i'm coming from nobody
helped no nobody did this
where do you come from from slovakia and
there is a really really like
i i mean for this hard time should
government more help them yeah
so i'm very pretty sure i'll live here
i'm very proud i move from there because
there's nothing help
[Music]
a bit further south to county durham a
lot has changed in bishop auckland
six months ago the streets were busy and
so was sam's cafe
hi sam how are you how's it been
it's it's been it's been horrendous to
be perfectly honest with you
he was looking forward to brexit and a
wave of local investment
but coronavirus changed everything
the thing is the generations yeah
my father my grandfather my
great-grandfather
this business still traded well during
world war one
yeah the spanish flu world war ii it
still traded
things went on this was a totally
different kettle of fish because
this business had to close down yeah and
and
to a certain point i felt as if
i was a failure i felt in my own mind
that i was a failure to the family
because are you sure it closed it closed
yeah but you couldn't have done anything
i know i couldn't no but
it's it you can't help thinking these
things are just going through your mind
all the time
and then when we reopened on june the
first just for takeaways only
and i was terrified what the name would
come
yeah i was terrified i didn't know what
to expect and the first week was really
really tough
but persevered and
things have got better as the week's
gone on
you know you said you'd voted for lots
of different parties and you'd voted for
different leaders
how do you think he's doing six months
in so i think all in all i think
i think the government have done really
really well and i think that they've
done their utmost best to support
and to to support businesses as well
but they spent a lot of money spent a
lot of money um
what do they have to do now boris
johnson's promise in that speech
that he did his bill bill bill's speech
and he said that he was sticking to that
level in upper gender he absolutely has
to do that
however we end up paying for it it has
to be done
they have still got to deliver in this
neck of the woods
from five years time in another town in
county durham support for the government
more qualified
david thought boris johnson was the
right man for brexit
but perhaps not for this crisis
how does the government have done do you
think they've done an okay job managing
it
at first i would you know i mean i've
always been a
labor supporter enough afforded brexit
actually i didn't vote conservatory but
i would thought i was more for boris
than i was for for labor yeah yeah
but as it's gone on and on it seems to
you know when the dominic cummings thing
and things like that you know i was
religiously watching
sky news all the time and now i've just
dropped off it all together
did you what did you think of the
dominic commons incident
well i was disgusted the fact that he
came to hear you
with with the virus when they're telling
us not to do anything
and then he can just stroll here and
probably sit on this bench
do you trust the government when they're
managing this stuff and managing us
because the first massive thing i think
we would have been
wearing fierce mass right from the start
we've spent a couple of days in the
northeast talking to people about
coronavirus and the government and the
main takeaway is that people are
willing to give boris johnson the
benefit of the doubt when it comes to
handling
the crisis and they certainly like the
business support that the government has
offered
but they also expect that those
manifesto commitments are delivered they
want to see
a leveling up of the country they want
more investment
into the northeast and that raises a
problem for the government and the prime
minister because he made those promises
when our economy was strong and growing
and now we're facing
the prospect of a very deep and
prolonged recession
so the obvious question is can they
still deliver on those pledges
and if they do how on earth are we going
to pay for it
since this crisis began regional
disparities have widened and things are
going in the wrong direction for the
northeast
the promise to rebuild will be hard to
keep
beth rigby sky news